[Music]
[Music]
members
officers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if the firearm goes off please exit by
the two
large fire doors and make your way
around to the car park
we are not expecting a drill today so
any alarm
will treat it as a true alert
we have waged any requirement for
standing
at today's meeting this will help us to
comply with the health and safety
regulations
and also provide a better sound through
the microphone
before we drew on the item properly can
i just welcome
new counselors today welcome to
a new encounter who are counter-trouble
claps and wheelhouse welcome to your
first council meeting
apologies for absence we have
apologies from countless hearts
barry rouse
stone ridgway
wright dale
[Music]
elliott putcherton
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
board members
counterparts
okay
uh
[Music]
[Music]
okay
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
accountability
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
no other comments
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sorry thank you
[Music]
since it was launched in 1948
during the 19 pandemic the valley work
of our nhfs
[Music]
so much however
many have lost their lives as a result
of coping 19
[Music]
for those in the nhs and frontline
workers
who have lost their lives in the
pandemic
we also call to mind everyone we know
who are no longer with us because
you
uh
you
thank you on the fifth of july
i joined sac at
to mark nhs social care and frontline
workers
particularly with being with any get sat
on the ipu ward for two
in remembrance of all those who have
lost their lives
we had the privilege of meeting a
cross-section of sap
to hear about their experiences during
the pandemic
on behalf of the council i thank saf for
all they continue to do
for every single person
i was also able to convey
congratulations on the award of the
george cross
this is in recognition of dedicated
service
and courageous efforts of all health
care workers
across the country
everyone is aware of the amazing work of
absent crosstalks there
i am grateful to colleagues who are
supporting my appeal for the charity
i wish to thank morgan single houston
builders
and the pagoda foundation for ensuring
the success of a charity football match
[Music]
i'm appreciative of all those who came
along to the gym and team safety meeting
last
[Music]
september i have an amazing new toilet
that plays abba songs when you're
flushing
water
[Music]
finally
i convey congratulations to the england
football team
on getting to the final of the euros
i made a special mention of harry
maguire brother of lawrence maguire
who is strongly
[Music]
there is no place for it in our society
thank you guys
um
my congratulations
national league of football
and i know um there's some anxiety
[Music]
uh
staff members
planning and um success the very context
of these shows
[Music]
my congratulations
um
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
questions will be given by the
appropriate cabinet member
so the following questions have been
received from members of the public the
first one
the question submitted by dr turner is
not
attending today therefore the question
is withdrawn
the next question submitted by mr
[Music]
can you hear me
[Music]
some of the reasons in the debate are
rejecting the motion
seems to center around achieving that
zero carbon
emissions by a certain date
and that will drop back the birth does
not satisfy zero carbohydrates
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um yes we support the ultimate aim
of this private member still to address
the very obvious problems because
climate change done by a diversity loss
because it's a council with different
amanda by our electorate
to run a variety of services such as
wage collection legislation
and we're not given a mandate it doesn't
matter
you
the national parliament each public body
needs to
focus spending on achieving its heart as
a hugely selective global endeavor
otherwise you just end up keep taking it
full of efforts and making very slow
progress i'm proud of this sound for
work
on climate change and of the great job
our officers are doing
and our level of commitment completing
our carbon emissions is clear
[Music]
and working with the community for
example introducing the panic attack
program to encourage residents to reduce
their own carbon footprint
i will also add that the uk has one of
the strongest status quo
amongst high income countries
[Music]
for example with ambiguous
[Music]
manufacturers setting up extensive
electric car and battery production in
the uk
for this administration will not be
reconsidering our score for this
private membership but we will continue
to work
with massively important issues
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
instead of focusing on bringing down our
recycling rates or
increasing premium for bringing down our
emissions
we'll be busy using valuable time on
matters that they
don't really have that much influence
over so individual councillors of course
can
raise matters against their issues
[Music]
leaver into counselor jeremy peninsula
[Music]
so i'm having trouble
[Music]
[Music]
i appreciate that the district council
is making changes to limit its own
carbon emissions
and i also appreciate that the
environmental
impact of the district's council's own
activities
is a very tiny fraction of the total
impact
of the activities of old district
residents and businesses
we all know from personal experience
that the biodiversity of our planet
[Music]
and is if the collapse is not holding
this will quickly
result in a worldwide crop failure
compounds
also science tells us that without very
rapid movements
the carbon detects
[Music]
[Music]
and human behavior everywhere must
change rapidly and that district
councils everywhere
are uniquely so imperative enable their
own constituents to adopt equal friendly
behavior
[Music]
against climate change and biodiversity
loss
greatly increased and frequent
consultation
with the public it's key to achieving
agreements on the changes needed
we'll say therefore a regularly meeting
and pressures in monthly
uh yes both myself and this council were
very much aware of the need for rapid
attention to address climate change and
biodiversity loss
that's why we passed their finance
emergency motion in 2019
it's why we're investing millions of
pounds in computing our carbon emissions
and taking action wherever it's within
our roommate it has been decided for
this council
many times now we have a clear to
address our operational
to work in our community as a whole and
that is what we will use our resources
for
we also consult with many excerpts and
assessments about what we can do to beat
our carbon footprint
a lot of very technical work um
not
[Music]
[Music]
specifically with regards to climate
change
[Music]
a thousand residents which is critical
to addressing our collective carbon
footprint
and if those hundred thousand residents
now think that we need to encourage and
[Music]
there's a risk that working on pilot to
change matters is going to be
discredited by
striving to set the voices from um
from um individuals it's
a group project and we've got this
parent
about hundred thousand residents with us
and that is a very difficult thing to
achieve
[Music]
louder than words and this
administration will maintain its focus
on our units and achieving actual
emission productions
and you just need to look at northeast
south particularly cycling rates
which is far higher than the average
neighbouring council to see that we are
walking the walk and not just talking
the talks
so we will engage with local groups as
and when it is appropriate and resources
but we will remain focused on the doing
believe it you want to say supplementary
questions
yes well my question
is really about that 100 000 people
and the way that the council
encourages them to help
because we can't carry on
without the health of the population so
i was pleased that the recent northeast
celebrations of council news magazine
encouraged all residents i think the
item was called
cancer from encouraging all residents to
reduce their impact on the climate
and environment and describe several
ways to do this
this had a very good effect in getting
people talking and thinking about
their climate and ecological
responsibilities
in a very positive way i've
[Music]
yes the summer revision
has not taken this what can we all do
further people do read this magazine
and there are so many things you have
the power to influence
more cycling slower rising
greater use of boosters and less
reliance on the motor cars
[Music]
is
with such excellent suggestions in each
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you do have several things without
climate change
uh in particular one of the first things
has come the office has been working in
the background on that
because it's become not just searching
for north east side but for the whole of
derbyshire
so we're working with seven other
districts in the county
to develop that program we've now got
two providers involved in it
um you'll have heard one of them i guess
that's probably
not name of them we've got two providers
involved in that
it doesn't happen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you thank you
participation rules
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in september there is
[Music]
um
any comments or questions
um
and we have a lot of members who are
working
and you need to find the time to be able
to get to these meetings
and someone can't get away from their
kids
where does that reason have been
completely involved
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
different ways
[Music]
uh
um
[Music]
questions
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
will
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
amendment
[Music]
um
[Music]
meeting um adopt the political balance
that you were adopted on the 16th of
[Music]
november
[Music]
um
are there any questions
[Music]
um
[Music]
against
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
any
[Music]
i'm happy to support the nomination
that's stupid thank you all those in
favor of independent groups
[Music]
thank stairs thank you um
any comments for questions
uh
[Music]
17.
to delegate
[Music]
as you'll be aware
[Music]
in order to deliver the government's
national policy on grants
to the businesses um
um
[Music]
again
[Music]
um
[Music]
budget monitoring annual governance
segment and safety of accounts are
probably
the most important coverage during the
year in 12 months
but of course the work plan covers a
number of pictures of
worst work the last 12 months have
included implications of the pandemic to
kobe 19
the implications of brexit including the
no deal brexit
we've looked at the cost of leisure
services
and there have been robust financial
bent marking
as well as a discussion about the risks
regarding
pensions so i can categorize
members here today that the committee
[Music]
members for the way that we have engaged
with all of that work with across
parties
so
[Music]
yes
be generated and to consider tactical
replacement budgets for the facilities
and equipment within the district parks
which is 24. uh
quite poignant around about
um
[Music]
evans
[Music]
we took on a review of tourism business
and non-business
it really was the perfect time as we
were in the depths of the pandemic
and the public's outlook to life was
certainly going to be altered with home
working etc
and the potential of this way of work
becoming the norm for some
and probably creating more leisure time
we can see the potential of our district
being in the middle of all this
beautiful countryside in the same flow
from major cities
council rennet renick kept us in her
loop with regards to the grace
strategy and kind of fed us with
information on tourism plans within the
district
we had meetings with other parties
having strategy
the growth manager economic growth
portfolio holder and also divolves over
the countryside partnership
the review did recognize measures the
council were involved in
to support local businesses but we found
there could be improvements in the
promotion of attractions
and we fully support the addition of a
tourism officer
that will certainly channel attention to
bring tourists to our door and also
improve the connectivity of the area
such as cycle path for example
thank you thank you 3.4 organisations
thank you
thank you during the year
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
the review uh reports of presenting a
federal class due to the member
of recommendations and
we also looked at the
human resources and organization
development which was considered
during 2021 and we support ourselves
issues during the 1920s which covered
irish areas
of recruitment and connection and
health foreign well-being initiatives
organization
development and apprenticeship and a
particular
interest as we're put towards items such
as
turnover between different services
the number of sickness absences and
targets that were set by the council
there was a general consensus that the
authority provided good support
for use which included an occupational
health provider and physiotherapist
[Music]
[Music]
the impact of the public spending on the
following transformation series
service confirmation conforming finances
digital organization
other organizational transformation and
environmental
transformation the general consensus
was that the adult working
policy should be implemented in a way
that it would actually
support the confirmation program and
they should pull fit
together it would widely recognize that
uh and agree
that going forward our working policy
should be flexible
and monitored on a regular basis to make
sure that it
[Music]
and is i would like to put my word of
thanks to the
staff who have supported the committee
throughout the year
under very difficult circumstances as
well
but also the rest of the commission
thank you are there any comments or
questions about the report
[Music]
again
[Music]
is
[Music]
but i still want to um it forward both
members
and i think it's particularly timely now
[Music]
um
uh
whilst all areas of the council
working alongside public health
engineering council
we've received funding from the
government council council to meet the
majority of these topics
which in total is more than an extra 200
000 pounds
which has enabled us to invest in
academic forces
and differences considerations have been
successful
and i'm pleased to update councils that
were spoken to thousands of residents
and businesses
and carried out hundreds of extra
proactive advice visits
balancing the need to advise businesses
with the result that we're trying to
change the service to meet these demands
in a different way
through things paragraph 2.8 roll out
for the noise monitoring app
and hotspot sailing technology alongside
this our environmental health service
for several
that's why last years at cabinet we
approved significant investments into
service alongside golf data
and police update council that this is
now paying dividends
and recent recruitment rounds have been
successful so far
with several new members
we're looking to accelerate our
productive work
and adopt new technology and ways of
working to hopefully meet the concerns
and priorities of our residents
this includes our flight shifting
reviews
new communications campaigns a potential
partnerships
regarding taxpayers
enforcement i'm happy to take any
questions the first step i'd like to
formally move the recommendations
and i'd also like to offer a thanks to
the leadership of our environmental
studies
[Music]
and to give
[Music]
excuse me
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
to also
is
in terms of reducing our carbon
emissions i think
that these should be published on the
website we might even
um
as well as
people understand what we are doing
rather than
[Music]
um
[Music]
um first of all regardless of what
happens with this particular emotion
uh and you can probably see the minutes
of the subgroup
[Music]
um
second thing uh personally um putting
more information on the website about
our method
and we can do that as well um however
what i would say is
it's not simple it's very much it's not
like a house where you measure
electrically from the gasoline from the
water
and you've got three
[Music]
on a regular numbers to see the news and
i don't think most of the residents
actually reach the minutes of
our council meetings uh we might want
them to
um the the news is obviously the best
way to communicate that
and even more so people can actually see
it with their
[Music]
and i wish you could do
[Music]
information every three
what we did in 2018-19 we calculated
baseline
identified whether our system reduction
is possible and then we focus on
achieving those and
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
we will report our progress
approximately annually
and um we will put some information on
the website
method thank you
[Music]
um
[Music]
and just publish what we can to the
eighth degrees
[Music]
and then
um
um
show up put it on the website tell
people are you doing it it just seems to
me
thank you
over the games
[Music]
is
[Music]
you
[Music]
together by the town of japan
association and i think he's got
crosstalk
support uh in parliament and
a lot of organizations are supporting
and some of these people are in the
wrong ones
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that the government and the big
developers
are getting away with it and it's a
government that set the housing momentum
building
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and at the consequences of these policy
decisions
far too many houses and i know we all
agree with this
have been delivered have been built in
the wrong standard
to the wrong standards in the wrong
place and they're lacking access
to basic services and i believe
we've set up for the government and the
big developers who are making millions
whilst in our communities our
communities are paying accord for this
the principles refer to this multi
supported provision of new affordable
homes
but they also recognize that these
owners need high environment
environmental and social standards
correct
they have to be climate charges and meet
people's basic needs for the lifetime
without the need for any expensive
refugees i think we can all accept that
four hours
affect every aspect of people's mental
and physical health therefore our
basically everyone
[Music]
thank you
uh
[Music]
[Music]
um
i think that's
[Music]
in the uh rates and with regards to
development
points i know that they've been
concerned
[Music]
the is good quality and related
environments
i think these are ranges with which we
all hopefully agree
uh today and i believe they are already
next to the two emerging teams and
students just coming through
northeast uh firstly there are patients
within the national planning changes
at the time of several planning
consultations which are on a variety of
things
and they're doing a really in detail
stage
discounts
and support the principles
[Music]
[Music]
by a building this healthy life caused
its design phone
which was introduced last year it's
being supported by the big stakeholders
with health england and has now been
rolled out uh
changes
um
cabinet
[Music]
and um campaign
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
indeed
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
because i certainly believe we already
have better
more work and more advanced
alternatives
um
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
thank you sir i just want to say very
local plants
is
and that's why it's so difficult to
actually provide quality
is
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
authorities would um taken away from us
uh and it's creating opportunities to
develop
in particular to come along
and create a massive
[Music]
on our health and yet you know it's
overwhelming
that too many new homes and
neighborhoods are seriously undermining
residents well-being and life chances
and these are some of the key things
that we need to be looking at
we should be
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
development rights and it's also being
noted by health professions that
live in substandard housing increases
the risk of range of preventable health
conditions such as respiratory
and cardiovascular disease as well as
mental health conditions such as
depression and anxiety
so we need to be looking at healthy
[Music]
to be homes and it's quite significant
and the other significant person in
addition to that is the current supply
of accessible adaptable housing in the
uk shopping alone
um
[Music]
and while around four hundred thousand
australians are living in homes
are unsuitable for them and uh
the current population owns in england
because outside london
is
[Music]
poor quality um unaffordable housing
disproportionately impact certain groups
including those from lowering from
households and people from minority
ethnic backgrounds
this gives opportunity for local
councils like
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
comments about the council that's not
the issue
uh and i praise signals and the council
for carrying on with the
you know the external world installation
or laptop on the council
the problem we've got
[Music]
uh
there's no players
[Music]
[Music]
that we as a council uh
looking at these teams we still don't
know all the other stuff
that you've created and but
the trouble is and when we were in
control
you get
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
again
the abstentions
[Music]
the following items of business to avoid
the disclosing for them of exact
information as defined in paragraphs one
two and three
part one of schedule 12 a local
government act 1972
as amended by the local government
access information
variation order 2006.
[Music]
that's all in favor
please